hi there steve kaufman here again
i've been asked to do a video comparing
classroom study to independent or online
study of languages
the
simple answer is that i think the
difference is that
online or rather independent study is
much more effective and much less
expensive than classroom study
and i'm going to explain why but then
i'm going to explain sort of a condition
all right
the reason i think that is that in my
own experience classroom study is very
ineffective now obviously if you have a
one-on-one relationship with a tutor
classroom study of that kind one-on-one
can be very effective but if you're in a
classroom with 5 10 15 or in some cases
in
in asia 70 in a classroom i don't think
you'll learn much in that scenario
the reason is that a lot of the time
you're listening to your classmates who
speak poorly i see the same result with
my grandchildren who are in french
immersion
they've had everything at school in
french since they started school they
take their chemistry their social
studies everything in french and yet
they have a very poor accent because
mostly they listen to each other
if
and i've mentioned before that the
majority of kids in canada who are in
the regular french stream after 12 years
or 10 years can't speak
if the same amount of time had been
spent
listening to
and reading content of interest with
occasional review
of the basic patterns of the language i
believe they would be better off
even if you are in a classroom
i think the learning takes place outside
the classroom again unless you're in a
one-on-one situation but if you're in a
class with five or ten people to me
that's not an environment conducive to
learning so you
the the classroom may inspire you may
set goals and of course the classroom is
a tremendous social environment you meet
your friends
but ultimately if you want to learn in a
classroom environment you have to after
the classroom listen read write speak to
people
and do all of the kinds of things that
you can do without the classroom now the
condition is that probably today a
majority of people
aren't motivated enough or don't have
enough confidence or don't know how to
learn languages so that they need the
classroom because without the classroom
they would not do much so to that extent
the classroom has the effect of of
putting the subject in front of people
giving them some objectives giving them
some tests to prepare for and forcing
forcing them to do things but if you are
motivated enough
to
learn on your own
then i think the classroom is is quite
unnecessary now
learning on your own though is people
have to learn how to do that and i've
posted a new post on my blog
and i'll leave a link here in the
description where i talk about learning
on your own and i think you need to have
a mix
between exploring the language exploring
different subjects via the language sort
of grazing
on the one hand which is maybe 70 or 80
percent of the time
and some more disciplined approach to
reviewing
in a very basic rote um
way
the main structures and patterns of the
language
recognizing that you will forget them
and they relearn them and forget them
and relearn them but some degree of
discipline
some effort to knock off sort of basic
simple tasks
that give you the sense of satisfaction
that you did something
needs to be mixed in with a more general
listening and reading
so if you proceed in that way
then there's no question in my mind that
learning on your own
is more effective and much less
expensive than learning in a classroom
however
maybe it's only a minority of people who
are capable of doing that i hope the
number of people who can learn
independently will
increase and you might also with
reference to that thought look at my
blog post on the subject of independent
learning thank you for listening bye for
now